hi everyone welcome to the fourth
lecture
today we'll be talking about
optimization-based Metal learning
um before that a couple reminders
um homework one is due on Wednesday so a
week from today uh we're also going to
post some project ideas suggestions
later today
[Music]
um
this won't be enough like we'll
hopefully have around 10 to 20 project
suggestions
um so I wouldn't necessarily rely on
these to like figure out exactly what
your project should be but if you want
some inspiration those should hopefully
be helpful
okay uh so for today
um we're gonna just briefly recap some
of the stuff that we talked about on
Monday with the meta learning problem
statement and black box meta learning
methods and then uh
we're gonna dive into optimization based
approaches to metal learning uh and uh
kind of optimization-based metal
learning will be part of homework too so
this should be pretty helpful for that
um and so the goals by the end of this
lecture are to try to understand
optimization-based by learning
techniques including how to implement
them and trade-offs between block box
approaches that we talked about on
Monday and optimization based approaches
that we'll talk about today
okay um so to recap what we talked about
on Monday uh we introduced the med
learning problem statement which is to
quickly learn a new task give an
experience from some set of previous
tasks
and this is different from the multitask
learning problem in the sense that you
ultimately want to solve a new task and
this is a bit different than the
transfer learning problem in that you
are given data from a number of previous
tasks and in terms of the methods we'll
actually see that metal learning methods
actually optimized for transferability
whereas transfer learning methods don't
do that
um in general in transfer learning and
metal learning it's impractical to
access the previous tasks when you're
trying to learn the new task I really
the dream is to be able to essentially
be able to um
solve a new task very quickly with
um some some parameters rather than
having to iterate over all of the data
from the previous tasks
and all these settings the tasks should
share some structure otherwise uh you're
better off learning from scratch
all right we also looked at an example
of metal learning problem which was a
five-way one shot image classification
problem
where you're given five examples
basically a little mini training data
set and you want to be able to
generalize to new examples using this
training data set
and the way that my learning algorithms
approach this problem is they assume
that they have
data from other image classes and they
structure these into train sets and test
sets and train a model such that after
it's used the training data set it can
generalize to new examples
so these are the training classes and
then we use these to try to generalize
to held out classes
and this is one example but you can
replace image classification with other
machine learning problems
okay and then the last thing that we
talked about on Monday was a kind of
Black Box approach to metal learning
where essentially what you do is you
just pass in the entire training data
set into a neural network and that
generates
um the weight Source on low dimensional
context vector and that's used to
predict the label for new examples
and so the general form of these kinds
of models is something that takes us
input the training data set and a new
example and is trained to Output the
correct label for that example
um the pros of this approach is that
it's a kind of very expressive neural
network very general form of
representing a learning procedure the
downside is that it's a very challenging
optimization problem to learn how to
learn from scratch
so in this lecture we're going to be
talking about a different way to
represent uh this kind of learning
procedure rather than representing it as
a black box neural network
and in particular we're going to be
thinking about actually representing
this learning procedure as an
optimization process with some
parameters such that we can optimize the
parameters of that optimization
procedure uh to be able to perform well
with small data sets
okay
um so
exactly what this exactly looks like is
instead of
passing these data points into a data
set we're going to run some optimization
procedure like gradient descent on our
trading data set
and this optimization procedure will
have some free parameters
uh and so really the key idea of these
optimization-based approaches is to try
to embed an optimization inside the meta
learning process
so that
um that optimization procedure does well
so overall one question is well why
might this make sense well
we probably saw fine tuning last time as
well we saw that fine-tuning works
pretty well it doesn't work that well
when you have a very small number of
data points but in general it it's
already doing a lot better than learning
from scratch
so essentially what we can try to do is
instead of uh
running fine tuning from a set of
pre-trained parameters we could actually
try to optimize for a set of pre-trained
parameters and other aspects of this
fine-tuning procedure in a way that that
fine-tuning procedure works well for
small data sets
and so in particular we want to just be
able to run an optimization procedure at
test time with our small data set
and what we're going to do is we'll take
this fine-tuning procedure
and we want to optimize such that this
fine-tuning procedure generalizes well
to test examples
and so we want to take the results of
this fine-tuning procedure and optimize
for how well those parameters generalize
to test data points
and in the simplest the simplest way
that we can do this is actually to
optimize
this objective with respect to the
pre-trained parameters
so we're going to optimize for a set of
pre-trained parameters such that
fine-tuning generalizes well with a
small data set
and uh we'll be doing this over all of
the meta training tasks uh so that we
were hopefully given a new task that
pre-trained parameters that set of free
training parameters works well for new
related tasks
so really the key idea here is to try to
learn a parameter Vector Theta that
transfers very well with fine-tuning
even when fine tuning operates with a
very small data set
now one way to visually depict this is
something like the following so say that
say that Theta is the kind of the
initialization the parameter Vector that
you're meta learning
um and maybe Phi isar is the optimal
parameter Vector for task I
then you can essentially think of it in
some way as this illustration right here
where when you're at this point during
The Meta training process and you take a
gradient step with respect to task three
you're quite far from the optimum for
task three
whereas kind of at the end of the
meditating process if you take a
gradient step with respect to task three
you want to be very close to the optimum
for task 3.
even if that gradient step is with
respect to a tiny data set
okay so this particular procedure is uh
referred to as model agnostic metal
learning in the sense that it is
agnostic to the model that you're using
as long as that model can be
uh it's kind of amenable to gradient
descent based um optimization
great so a couple questions here you
might notice that there's one gradient
step in the subjective here
um I'm writing that for Simplicity I in
many cases actually just a single
gradient step can actually perform quite
well but you can also replace that with
multiple gradient steps and optimize
such that a few steps of fine tuning
works well
yeah
yeah
the question is is this uh is this
picture in the parameter space and yeah
so this is trying to depict um like a 2d
parameter space essentially
um
foreign
procedure ends up at a point that is the
optimum for one of the tasks and and the
gradient would be zero in that case is
that what you're asking yeah
yeah so notice that that's that's that's
fine the grade it will be zero and then
for that task it will do well for that
task
um as long as it also can get to the get
to a good Optimum for all of the tasks
in your trading data set not just a
single task
so the question is does this assume that
the optimum are kind of close together
in the parameter space
um and uh one thing that I'll mention
here is I think that this graphic is
helpful for understanding the algorithm
and visual visualizing it but in reality
you won't just have a single Optimum uh
a single good parameter that's good for
that task in reality you actually have
an entire space of parameters that is
useful for that task and especially as
you move into higher Dimensions the um
kind of the space of of Optimal
Solutions and good solutions for our
given task we'll get larger
um and
uh so that's one thing is that usually
it's not just a single point um and then
second uh if you if you allow this to
use a relatively large step size or use
multiple gradient steps that allows it
to potentially move further in parameter
space that said it is kind of implicitly
making some assumption that you can
there is a spot where you can get to a
good performance for each of the tasks
within a small number of gradient steps
and so that is some implicit assumption
in practice we actually find that uh
that um the Assumption or at least the
algorithm works well in a wide variety
of problems
um
yeah that's a great way to put it so
essentially the goal of the algorithm is
not to get a parameters set of
parameters that works well for all the
tasks and set it to get to a space in
parameter space such that you can
quickly get to a good solution for each
of the tasks
um
yeah exactly
yeah so when you're given a new task
then you just have these set of
parameters and you can essentially just
run fine tuning a few steps of fine
tuning you could also run more steps to
fine-tuning potentially if you have the
compute
yeah so
we'll have I'll put this via hyper
parameter um you can also actually learn
Alpha as well and we'll talk about that
in a few places
this picture it kind of looks like the
best
um
yeah
um so the question is uh it looks like
the optimal is just kind of almost
averaging it's not quite averaging but
in this picture it looks like it's
similar to averaging and how does it
compare to Simply averaging good
parameters
um one of the things that actually makes
averaging not necessarily perform well
is that if you actually have a very
large space of parameters that works
well for each task if you optimize each
of them independently and then take the
average you may actually end up like
depending on where those optimizations
landed you may actually end up at a
point that is actually
potentially very weird
um and not very good in parameter space
um and so in in practice averaging
usually doesn't perform as well
um
yeah
exactly so we're operating in the few
shot learning procedure where we have a
small number of labeled examples and
we're running a great data set on those
labeled exams
okay I'm going to run through the
algorithm and then we can maybe get
through some more questions so
um if we hold a kind of approach for
Black Box meta learning we sampled a
task we sampled these data sets we
compute the parameters using our Black
Box model and then update the parameters
data by kind of differentiating through
that Black Box model
really the only thing that is different
with the optimization based approach is
instead of
optimizing the parameters by passing
them through this block box neural
network instead we're going to be
running one or a few steps of gradient
descent
uh and that's that's basically it that's
the only difference from
um from the Black Box approaches
so um
there's a couple things that's worth
mentioning here that you might notice
uh so the first is that
we have a gradient
here we're trying to
um we're kind of running gradient
descent r on our objective on our meta
objective and there's also a gradient
with respect to Theta inside that
objective
and as a result this means that we are
actually getting second order
derivatives in this optimization problem
because we are
taking we have a gradient and we have
another gradient so we're taking the
gradient of a gradient which will give
us the second derivative
um
and so you might be wondering like maybe
you actually have to compute the full
Hessian uh which would be rather
unfortunate because the fashion will be
if you have a neural network of size
with parameters with n parameters then
the full hession will be n times n and
we don't want to have to compute
something that's quadratic in our
parameters
another thing you might notice is well
what if we run multiple gradient steps
in the in the Inner Loop um does that
mean that we'll actually get higher
order derivatives like third order
derivatives
um
and so
I'll run through kind of
the answer to these questions on the
Whiteboard but I'm curious if anyone has
any initial thoughts on
whether we need to compete the full
Hessian or whether we need higher order
derivatives
any thoughts yeah
of course
yeah so I can first go over to the
second question and the answer is indeed
no and the reason for that is that when
you are
um
Computing Phi I when you're trying to
kind of estimate the the parameters for
a task if you run multiple gradient
steps in the Inner Loop then this is
going to be Theta minus
the gradient of
um all of theta on the train data set
and then when you take the second
gradient step
you're going to be taking that at the
value of this so if we refer to this as
Theta Prime then the next time we take
the gradient it will be the second
gradient step will be with respect but
to Theta Prime rather than with respect
to Theta
um and then when you eventually need to
differentiate all of this with respect
to Theta
um
you don't actually ever see
any there aren't any second order terms
in here and so when you need to
differentiate Theta through here I only
get second order terms coming up
um
in terms of the gradient of the meta
objective and no like third order terms
for example
foreign
yeah so the um the the suggestion was
that there's an algorithm called imammal
that'll actually cover in several sides
um that can actually get away from using
the full Hessian by using What's called
the implicit function theorem
um but I guess even for the original
mammal algorithm I'm wondering not the
Imam algorithm even for the original
memo algorithm do we need to compute the
full Hessian
so the questions can we use natural
gradient
into the fashion
um
you might be close but I'm not sure
uh
you couldn't wait you could just ignore
the Hessian uh you could throw away the
second ordered gradients and derive a
first order version of the algorithm and
actually the first order version
sometimes performs surprisingly well but
um
that's not quite what I'm looking for
so you could try to approximate the
Hutchins
um that would still not give you the
kind of exact meta gradient but it's
definitely a valid solution
do you think you're a procedure where
you kind of alternate between the two
um I'm not sure how exactly that would
work
okay maybe I'll
go through the answer so
um and actually this will involve a
little bit of a digression so one thing
that's pretty cool
um
that I didn't know about actually for
um until sometimes uh if you have a
Hessian
um
in many cases when you actually need to
compute the Hessian you only need to
compute Hessian Vector products and so
say um
say you have some function at F of theta
and then maybe let's use G of theta to
denote the gradient of F and let's use
H sub Theta to denote the um the Hessian
in many cases so Computing the full
session is very nasty but in many cases
we actually only need to actually
compute
what's called a Hessian Vector product
which is basically
the Hessian multiplied by a vector
and
it turns out as I'll show in a minute
the
uh you can actually when you actually go
about Computing this you don't actually
need to compute the full Hessian you can
you only you essentially just need to
compute a Hessian Vector product and
there are much cheaper ways to compute a
Hessian Vector product than constructing
the full Hessian and then doing a matrix
Vector multiplication
um and one uh I guess with regard to the
the point of actually approximating the
Hessian one pretty cheap way to
um
to actually estimate the session Vector
product is through something uh called
finite differences where you
um
essentially do finite differences on the
gradient of the function
and in particular you can
write this as being approximately equal
to the
gradient of
of the function evaluated at R times V
minus
the gradient of the function
divided by r
so essentially this is just doing finite
differences on your gradient it's
comparing the gradient after
um the gradient at the function compared
to the gradient at the function plus
plus v
multiplied by some R and this is becomes
more and more accurate when R is small
and one of the things that's nice about
this is that to compute this you
actually just need to evaluate the
gradient twice
you don't actually need to
um
you don't need to actually compute the
full Hessian
now this is an approximate way to
estimate the session Vector product
uh there is actually a more exact way
that is
um that doesn't have a numerical
stability you might notice that there's
an R here and so if R is really small
you're going to get numerical stability
issues
um and so there's something
called um
Pearl Mudders method which is named
after uh
Pearl Mudder and that essentially gives
you a way to do something like this
except in an exact way that isn't
numerically unstable
it's a great question
um does does like tensorflow and Pie
torch already do this for you
um and uh essentially do these
approximation methods and
the um it essentially does it uses I
believe it uses promoters method um
which is actually an exact way that does
something very similar to this except um
uh in a way that essentially is just
about as expensive as Computing a
gradient
um and so in some ways you don't
actually need to worry about this at all
because pytorch or tensorflow will do it
all for you
um but I think it's useful to understand
that uh
when you're actually running this
algorithm tensorflow and pytorch doesn't
need to actually compute the full
Hessian in order to optimize this
objective
a little bit
yeah exactly so if our goal is to
optimize
um we essentially want to optimize the
um
something like this evaluated on the
test which is equal to
um
L of theta minus Alpha grad
um Theta l
D train evaluated at d-test
um if we want to optimize this we can
use the chain Rule and it will
essentially give us something when we
take the gradient of this with respect
to Theta we will get something that
looks like
essentially DL
D Phi
um evaluated
at Phi equals 1 minus Alpha grid so
um times
D Phi D Theta
this is just using the chain rule this
is the gradient of the outside this is
the gradient of the inside
with respect to Theta
and um
this is just essentially the same as
running back profit in a standard way
through the neural network and this is
where things get a little bit more
complicated
um
essentially if we want to evaluate the
gradient of this with respect to Theta
um
Define d Theta is we can't take the
gradient of the first thing which is
this eye
and then we take the gradient of the
second thing which is equal to the
Hessian
and
um
and so this is where the Hessian pops up
but fortunately when we need the
gradient of the entire expression we get
this is a vector this is a row Vector
this is the this is a matrix and we get
this expression times this expression
and So eventually we get a Hessian
Vector product from here
data
yeah so if you um if you eventually have
two inner gradient steps uh instead of
one this is the the gradient of Phi with
respect to Theta for one gradient step
if you have two it ends up looking like
um
uh the the Hessian at Theta Prime
of L times
D Theta Prime D Theta
um and so
this only has second order terms in here
we multiply this by the vector here we
actually get two Hessian Vector products
once we have two inner gradient steps
but we don't get any like third order
terms which is good news
okay
any questions on this
so to summarize we have a nice way to
compute Hessian Vector products that
requires
um it takes about the the kind of
computation as um taking one or two
gradient steps and then uh when we
actually write out the objective we get
a row Vector times a matrix and this
Matrix includes Hessian terms but
luckily we're we need to multiply this
by this row Vector
um
and that allows us to use this the
sufficient hectation Vector method for
computing the gradient of the meta
objective
yeah
the last names
yeah this is if you take two gradient
steps in the Inner Loop um if you take
three gradient steps in the Inner Loop
you'll have another another term
and I should maybe double check that I
actually did that right
I think that that's right
yeah
yeah they don't need to be the same as
actually there is a paper that showed
that using using different gradient
steps for the two steps can be
um like a larger one for the first step
that's a smaller one for the Second Step
um I'm just doing that for Simplicity
Okay so
now how does this approach compare to
the Black Box approach
um we saw that at the algorithmic level
it just corresponds to running a
different inner inner loop procedure for
computing task specific parameters
and so if we look at kind of the form of
these two functions uh one is one where
we kind of pass in the data set into a
neural network and then the other is one
where
um where we essentially are running
gradient descent on the training data
set
um and so in many ways the general form
is the same both of them are a
computation graph that takes his input a
training data set and a test input
but in one case we're just passing all
that into a black box neural network and
the other case we're running gradient
descent and evaluating the test input on
the updated parameters
um so yeah essentially mammal can be
viewed as just a different computation
graph that embeds this gradient operator
into the computation graph
um which is in some ways very similar to
the Black Box approach we're just
building in some more structure about
optimization into that learning
procedure
um it's also worth mentioning that you
can potentially mix and match components
of these computation graphs
and so for example you could learn the
initialization but replace the gradient
update with um with some form of learned
Network
um where you actually have like a
network that takes the input a gradient
step
um and there's a paper by Sachin Ravi
and Hugo larochelle that actually
predates mammal
um that that does something like that
okay
um in general this sort of like
computation graph view of metal learning
will actually come up again in the next
lecture when we talk about uh
non-parametric approaches
okay now you might be wondering wouldn't
we use one approach versus the other
um
one thing that's nice about embedding a
gradient step into the optimization
procedure is that it means that at test
time you're just running fine tuning and
so regardless of what happens during The
Meta training process you're still
running an optimization procedure that
should get better at the test task
and so if you look at tasks that are
extrapolated from the tasks that you saw
during meta training
um
these optimization-based approaches like
mammal often do actually better than
Black Box approaches
and so for example if you compare mammal
with snail and meta networks which are
two black box approaches
you can look at say like omnigot
classification
and look at the performance of the
algorithm as you vary the test tasks as
you move them away from the the
distribution that they saw during meta
training
so for example maybe we met a trained on
top on on digits that are upright and
then we're evaluating on tasks where the
digits are skewed
then in this case you see that
performance deteriorates As you move
away from the kinds of tasks that you
saw during meta training but it
deteriorates a lot less for our mammal
style algorithm compared to these black
box algorithms
and kind of the intuition here is that
if you're feeding in out of distribution
tasks into a black box neural network
you don't really have any reason to
expect it to generalize whereas if
you're running gradient descent on out
of distribution images you can at least
expect it to improve on the objective
just like fine-tuning improves
um we can also look at something like
the scale of the digits and we see
um somewhat of a similar Trend where
mammal is a bit better at extrapolating
yeah exactly so
um what's happening at test time for the
Black Box methods is it's passing in the
support set into the neural network
whereas for Mammal it's taking the
support set and running gradient descent
on them and these plots are showing the
performance after using the support set
to adapt to the task
um now the only thing you might wonder
is well okay we're building a gradient
step into this procedure does this mean
that we are less that the method is less
expressive like maybe it can't represent
the kinds of learning procedures that a
black box neural network can represent
um and one thing that you can show is
that if you have a sufficiently large
neural network
then the computation graph with the
gradient descent step in it can actually
still approximate any function of the
training data set and the test input
um
and essentially this is saying that you
can represent any learning procedure
despite the fact that there's a gradient
update in the computation graph
and this is under a few different
assumptions I need to assume that the
the learning rate is non-zero of course
so that the the gradient is actually
having an effect
um you need to see that the loss
function gradient doesn't lose
information about the label uh
so this is true for for loss functions
like cross entropy and L2 loss
and you also need to assume that the
data points in the train data set are
unique
um and this is interesting because this
means that in some ways mammal has the
benefit of
building the structure or inductive bias
of gradient descent compared to these
black box approaches without necessarily
losing the expressive power that you get
from a like kind of a neural network
representing a learning procedure
so
um
in some ways this is a kind of more
advanced material but essentially
[Music]
um
if you view mammal as a computation
graph that has a gradient inside of it
um the
uh I guess
essentially what I mean is that if you
look at a loss function
like um like an L2 loss function
then the slope the gradient of this is
actually changing and you can figure out
like where what point on this curve You
Are by looking at the gradient
whereas if you have a loss function
that is more like
an L1 loss function
then in that case if you look at the
gradient
um it is actually it isn't actually that
informative about what the label is
because the gradient is the same here as
it is here and so forth
um and so
generally if you use loss functions like
this you're going to have a less
informative gradient update potentially
in practice mammal can still work with
these but if you need a very expressive
update rule that maybe is a little bit
different than gradient descent these
might not work as well
foreign
and then
the last thing to mention on these
optimization based approaches is some of
the challenges that come up and the ways
that we can fix them
and this essentially will yield
different variants of these
optimization-based metal learning
algorithms
um so the first is that we do have this
bi-level optimization procedure in the
sense that there's an optimization
embedded inside an optimization
and this in general can lead to
instabilities
yeah
um so the question was why do the data
points need to be unique
um
and essentially the reason for this is
that
um
if you if you want to be able to
represent any learning procedure with
respect to different copies of a data
point it's generally difficult to tell
from the gradient how many copies of a
data point you have
um if you don't care about it depending
on the number of copies that it's then
it's generally fine
um it's only a matter of like whether
you want the learning procedure to do
something different when you have like
five copies versus four copies
of a data point which is usually not not
the case
okay um so how can we get get over the
um the challenge of these like
instabilities that might arise from the
bi-level optimization
um there's a few different approaches
that uh that have been used one is
um when you have your your inner
learning rate instead of having it fixed
as a hyper parameter
you can essentially learn it
and this gives the algorithm more
flexibility in how it chooses this
optimization procedure
and one thing that you could do is
instead of having it be a scalar
function you can have it actually just
be a vector you can have a different
learning rate for each layer or a
different learning rate for each
parameter
and in general giving it the flexibility
to have different learning rates for
different layers can be quite helpful
because for example the biases of a
network may want to have larger
gradients than the weights of the
network or maybe the later layers of the
network want to change more whereas the
earlier layers of the network should
change less
um
there are all sorts of approaches that
optimize only a subset of the parameters
in the Inner Loop um you can optimize
like just the last layer of the network
for example or optimize
um like some some multiplicative factors
on uh on different layers
um and then one other thing that came up
is like you don't necessarily have to
have the same
learning rate for each of the different
steps and so what you could do is you
could try to essentially decouple the
learning rate and other things like the
bathroom statistics for different steps
in the optimization
um and then uh there's also approaches
that uh introduce try to introduce some
additional context variables into the
network uh to try to increase generally
just increase the expressive power of
this
um of the meta learning algorithm
and so really the takeaway here is that
um not necessarily to understand the
details of all of these different
approaches but just to understand that
there's a variety of simple tricks that
can help improve the stability of the
optimization
okay
and then the second challenge that comes
up is that uh you do have to back
propagate through this optimization
procedure and if you have one gradient
step that's not too hard but if you have
a lot of gradient steps then optimizing
through all of those gradient steps can
be computationally expensive and also
memory intensive because you have to
store the the optimization in in memory
there's a few different approaches for
trying to solve this particularly in
cases where you want to have a large
number of inner gradient steps
um one is to just ignore the fact that
there are second order gradients
um just essentially when you're
Computing
um
when you're Computing the the gradient
just cruelly approximate this as
identity
and
um this is a
not at all principled
um often because this is not anywhere
close to Identity usually
um but in practice it actually works
surprisingly well uh on certain problems
on other problems it doesn't work at all
but anecdotally uh it it can work for
problems like Fusion image
classification
um and yeah I'll leave it at that
um another approach is to only optimize
the last layer of the network
and essentially what this is going to
correspond to is optimizing for a
representation such that if you train a
linear layer on top of that
representation
you can perform the task well
um and there's a few different
approaches that have done this where
they do like Ridge regression or
logistic regression on top of the
features or they do a support Vector
machine on top of those features
and it leads to uh often leads to
actually a fairly nice optimization
procedure compared to the bi-level
optimization that you see
um
when you're kind of trying to back
propagate through gradient Descent of
the entire network
great and then the last thing that you
can do is um something else that was
mentioned which is to try to use What's
called the implicit function theorem to
derive The Meta gradient
and one of the things that's cool about
this is you could actually compute The
Meta gradient without actually
differentiating through the optimization
path by essentially using curvature
information at the um at the end of the
optimization path
um I'm not going to go through in detail
how exactly you do this because it's not
something that's particularly intuitive
but if you want to learn more about it
I'd encourage you to we can take a look
at this paper you can also take a look
at what's known as the implicit function
theorem
uh and you get um some kind of
interesting trade-offs in terms of uh
memory and uh and computation so if you
plot the number of inner gradient steps
on the x-axis
and the amount of GPU memory that you
need if you use the implicit function
theorem this stays constant whereas it
increases linearly for
um for an approach that just uh
that just back props through the the
computation graph and then the
computation time also stays flatter
compared to back propagating through the
entire procedure I mean this purple line
is the first order approximation
um which also is a shallower line as
well
um the other thing that's kind of cool
about this is it also allows you to do
second order optimizers in the Inner
Loop
um because you don't actually have to do
a second order optimization for the
entire thing
and so it allows you to get
um kind of better performance in some
cases by leveraging those second order
optimizers
and the implicit function theorem is
also useful for for hyper parameter
optimization as well there's a pretty
cool paper that essentially optimizes
for data augmentation procedures using
ideas like the implicit function theorem
okay
um and then lastly the other thing worth
mentioning is that the um you want to
choose an architecture that that works
well in general the procedure is model
agnostic and should generally work well
for a variety of architectures
um but there is a um some works that
actually tried to search for an
architecture that works well with these
kinds of algorithms
um it actually found a pretty
non-standard architecture and was able
to
um I was able to get uh
essentially like a 10 performance boost
by actually optimizing for an
architecture rather than using a more
basic architecture
great um so I'll summarize things and
then we can uh then we can run through
any more questions so uh really the key
idea here is we're going to try to get
some task specific parameters from the
support set by running fine tuning
and the approach has
conservative high level optimization
problem and this has a positive
inductive bias because you're
essentially defaulting to fine-tuning
it also tends to extrapolate better by
using the
structure of fine tuning
it's also maximally expressive if you
have a sufficiently large Network and it
is model agnostic so it should be fairly
straightforward to combine with your
favorite architecture
the downsizes that it typically requires
a second order optimization
and this means that it can be compute or
memory intensive
okay any any questions on on how things
work or things that would be that might
be helpful
or any questions on the the math or
anything
yeah definitely so
I guess one thing that I never really
outlined is that so I talked about the
um
I talked about this procedure where we
sample a task sample a support set at a
query set and then run gradient descent
on the support set and then optimize for
the performance of those updated
parameters on the query set and then
what happens at test time is you
take the the Learned initialization
these parameters data and you just run
gradient descent on them
and so if you're given a task that is
completely out of distribution from what
you saw before
at the very least you are running
gradient descent you're running fine
tuning on that task
and so
we can expect fine tuning to already do
fairly well on a variety of tasks and so
you shouldn't expected to do it at least
as well as fine-tuning on out of
distribution tasks
now in contrast with the black box
approach where you are passing the data
points into a neural network
if you pass it out of distribution
examples into a neural network
uh you can't really expect it to do
anything reasonable and it will probably
do worse than fine-tuning will do
and so as a result um you can expect
methods like these optimization-based
meta learning methods to do a lot better
on auto distribution tasks than Black
Box approaches
this also relates to a question I think
that from yesterday in terms of like the
robustness of these methods as well
during training
um
yeah it's a good question so
um typically in the Inner Loop you often
use one step mostly just for
computational reasons uh it can be
challenging to back propagate through a
lot of gradient descent steps it also
seems to work pretty well but then like
you mentioned at test time computation
is no longer a bottleneck because you're
just running the procedure once and you
don't need to back propagate through it
and so in practice it is um it is pretty
common to actually just run more
gradient step to some steps at test time
um and uh and that can perform well and
that can be especially helpful for for
auto distribution tasks for which you
might need more more fine-tuning
compared to the small number of gradient
steps that's optimized for for the end
distribution tasks
[Music]
all right
now so like using that on the phone
and
yeah
right so at this time you're running
fine tuning and the question was it
seems like that might be expensive to do
like on a phone for example when if you
don't have the GPU and this is where
some of the algorithms that only update
the last layer could be very helpful
um and uh and you don't necessarily need
to have this inner loop step optimize
everything
yeah uh I remember in the microwave
Hospital in optimization
possibility
optimization so I'm curious about why
not available
yeah so the question is um in a
reinforcement learning setting the
mammal paper uses like vanilla
reinforcer policy gradient
um we'll get to reinforcement learning
topics in in several lectures but the I
mean the main reason is that the um like
an objective like trpo is does involve a
um kind of like a higher order
optimization I also think that PPO
didn't yet exist at the time but if
something like that existed then that
would be a reasonable option as well
yeah
so the question is why do algorithms
that um like first order algorithms that
throw away this um or reptile which is
very similar to this kind of first order
approach uh why do they work well
um
I don't exactly know why they work well
I think it may actually have to do with
the question earlier about how
um
like in some cases it might be okay to
just average parameters that work well
um and I suspect that yeah I think there
are some cases where the kind of
parameter landscape is nicely behaved
such that um simple things like
averaging gradients of different tasks
performs um performs well in more
complex scenarios I have uh I found at
least that it can perform pretty poorly
uh these first order algorithms can
perform poorly yeah
um
yeah when I say that the first order
methods perform well I mean that they
perform about the same level as the
second order methods um on the simpler
problems
yeah
[Music]
single
location
yeah so the question is um for these
inner gradient steps I assume you mean
step three not step four right
um what if you have a large data set are
you using SGD here or something else
um and typically actually uh in most
cases these algorithms are applied to a
few short learning problems where you
have a relatively small data set but
actually this inner gradient step is
often computed with respect to all of
your data points not just one data point
um and if you have like 100 examples
that allows you to compute a gradient
that depends on all the examples rather
than just one
yeah so you're saying that it's often a
very good idea to just do one card step
in the world view for computational
reasons but it's also a good reason to
just prepare it
you have multiple you have access to
more
so you're asking um
does it make sense like does it
um does the there's one great using one
grain instead of an inner loop does that
make it harder
foreign
yeah so the question is uh by meditating
with one gradient step and meta testing
with more gradient steps does that
essentially make it easier
um a test time and yeah I think so I
think that the um
I think that that essentially encourages
it to to learn very quickly
um and uh and you are when you actually
have a longer optimization problem at
test time
um that that makes it a little bit
easier uh and um but the network should
still be able to learn quickly because
of the one inner gradient step
okay
um one more question but there's a
question
in the future
yeah so the question is is it because of
feature reuse that the kind of first
order method works better uh works works
well
um
I I think it could have to do with
feature reuse although I think that the
concept of feature reuse is a little bit
uh vague in some ways and not not as
precise
um but I think it could
um especially in computer vision
problems
okay
so now I'm going to run through a case
study and I think that this should be
pretty helpful because so far we've only
seen like image classification problems
where we're trying to classify a
category of an image and we'll look at a
case study that is um a bit different
than that example and it'll hopefully
illustrate the generality of these kinds
of metal learning methods
and so in particular this paper wanted
to be able to
predict land cover
and this can be useful for essentially
trying to monitor how the Earth is being
used over time and can be used for
various conservation efforts or or urban
planning or other things
um and it was not the kind of Earth
Vision Workshop in 2020 at cdpr
okay um and so the problem is they want
to map land cover from satellite images
sadly images are relatively cheap to get
uh getting land cover annotations
through on the ground surveys is a lot
harder to get and so they looked at a
couple different data sets one is the
data set right here where you have very
like low resolution
high level
segmentation of the land cover
and the second example is one that
actually has a much higher resolution uh
land cover segmentation and I'm showing
the different classes here so like Blues
corresponds to Urban regions green
corresponds to Forest regions and and so
forth
and this is applications in kind of
urban planning climate change research
and it has a number of talented so
labeling data like this is super
expensive because you need a label for
every region of pixels
and different regions also look
different as well and have different
land use proportions
and so they want to be able to frame
this as a meta learning problem
and um
as an example they have uh examples of
croplands of four countries is kind of
illustrating the kind of differences
that you see in different regions of the
world
and different tasks are going to
correspond to these different regions of
the world
and so hopefully we'll be able to
leverage a lot of annotated data from
some parts of the world to be able to
build a segment images from a new region
of the world with only a small amount of
data from that region
uh and so you can kind of uh this is a
graphic from the paper where they are
trying to run this kind of meta learning
process such that it allows them to
quickly adapt to different regions of
the world
um and learn a model that can segment uh
land cover in those different regions
okay
so
um first we'll look at uh this uh send
one Ms or send 12 Ms data set
um
and they had different uh
different kind of geographic metadata
um here's some examples of the images
and they're using the blue data points
for the blue regions for meta training
the light blue regions for like
validating and tuning the hyper
parameters of the metal algorithm and
then the orange for actually reporting
results and evaluating
um and so
as an example of a two-way two-shot
classification problem they have an
illustration here where they are trying
to classify
um
for example Forest versus uh croplands
and
they
um
they have kind of the samples correspond
to these different regions of the world
with labels and so they'll have k k
regions that are labeled and they'll
provide that to the algorithm and then
they want to be able to be able to
predict the land cover for other parts
of that particular region of the world
okay
um so that was the first day I said they
also looked at this deep Globe data set
unfortunately this data set didn't have
any Geographic metadata uh it didn't
actually have like coordinates
corresponding to where the satellite
images are coming from and so they had
to roughly guess from from the metadata
and they used clustering to do that and
then what the the few start learning
problem looks like is they're given kind
of one part of a region of the the world
and then they want to be able to
evaluate
um and make predictions for the land
cover in other regions
or other parts of the same region
um and so this was this was the days
that had also a much higher resolution
data sets and so ultimately they want to
be able to predict the labels that look
like this
okay um so they had meditating data
um and at a test time they're given a
small data set for a new region
and
um
this is kind of the
um the support set of the meta test task
and they compared uh just randomly
training on the support set of the
target task so this is just trading from
scratch on the support set for the test
task
they also compared to pre-training on
all of the Mediterranean data and then
fine-tuning a network on the data from
the target region
and then they also evaluated uh model
agnostic metal learning on the metatrain
data and then adopting with a small
amount of data on the target task
and so the results for the first data
set are here and they're plotting the
performance with different numbers of
examples
in their support set for the test task
and what they find is first um random
doesn't do very well they see a
significant performance improvement from
using a pre-trained network and they
also
um see a pretty big performance
Improvement I think around
10 to 20 percent when using meta
learning compared to using a pre-trade
model
um and then on the Deep Globe data set
um they found that mammal in a
pre-trained network performs somewhat
similarly when they have a random split
but then when they make it when they
give it a clustered split which is
harder and you have to adapt to regions
of the world that are probably different
from what was seen during mediter
training you see a much larger Gap in in
performance
great um and there's also more
visualizations and Analysis in the paper
this is just kind of a subset of the
results
any questions on the case study yeah
kind of below the performance of random
guessing uh the reason is that in mammal
you're optimizing for the performance
after fine-tuning and so the
pre-frontating model
um it might always like you're not
actually optimizing it for it to be good
in any way and it may actually be like
arbitrarily bad unless you actually tell
it to
um that it should actually be good and
so you can actually
um
one thing you could do is you could
actually optimize both for this
objective as well as like
the objective of the original parameters
as well
um and that's that's useful if you care
about the um the performance of the
model before fine tuning
yeah
yeah so I don't think that they compared
to a black box metal learning algorithm
in this paper I would expect it to
uh not perform as well
especially in in settings where like as
we saw before the the held out regions
um
different regions of the world look
quite different and so in some ways it's
like
um it's like it is somewhat out of
distribution and so the Black Box
methods probably wouldn't do as well in
this sort of scenario
um that's that they didn't evaluate it
uh and so I I don't know for sure
um
places
yes he's here
um
I believe that they randomly sampled the
locations and that should mean that
there's less hopefully less covariate
shift less distribution shift
um
the than you would otherwise
foreign
okay great
um
so
that's it for today we covered
optimization-based metal learning we
talked about how it differs with these
black box approaches as well as some of
the challenges and different ways to
tweak the method to address those
challenges and then we also saw a case
study of land cover classification
um
yeah and then in terms of kind of a road
map for what we're going to be seeing
next so far we've covered Black Box meta
learning and optimization based by
learning and there's one class of metal
learning methods left which is called
non-parametric Methods and so on Monday
next week we're going to cover these
methods and also just kind of compare
all the approaches from a high level
and then on Wednesday we'll look at some
more advanced topics uh but that are
quite important uh for thinking about
the performance of metal learning
algorithms and should have some
important implications if you choose to
use some of these algorithms for your
final project
and then uh
on um on Monday of the following week
we're also going to cover Bayesian kind
of Bayesian interpretation of metal
learning algorithms and then on
Wednesday of week four we'll start
covering reinforcement learning
um oh there we go following Monday is
patient medal learning and then uh
reinforcement learning um also project
proposals will be due on I think
Wednesday of week four and so it's good
to start thinking about your projects
now
um and so hopefully some of the project
ideas suggestions that we'll post will
be helpful for that